Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
L'allevamento intensivo
non è né sostenibile né efficiente.
Cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che se prendiamo i dati,
e facciamo due calcoli,
ci rendiamo conto che è abbastanza ovvio
che non possiamo andare avanti così.
Questo grafico, per esempio,
mostra le emissioni annuali
in anidride carbonica -
o equivalente, come il metano -
che risultano da deforestazione,
per esempio in Brasile.
Il primo prodotto, il peggiore di tutti,
è la carne, soprattutto quella di manzo:
guardate questo grafico.
Volete sapere qual è il secondo?
Non importa.
Non importa perché
[il manzo] è così grave,
che corrisponde al 91% delle ragioni
per cui si deforesta l'Amazzonia.
Lo dico di nuovo:
La carne, costringendoci a fare spazio
per il pascolo e il mangime degli animali,
è la ragione del 91%
della deforestazione in Amazzonia.
E in tutto il pianeta pure,
soprattutto nelle zone tropicali:
è anche in quelle [zone] la maggior causa
della deforestazione  -
nelle aree tropicali è il 41%.
Il secondo motivo
è ancora qualcosa di simile:
nel Borneo, per esempio,
è l'olio di palma e altri oli.
Quindi non si tratta solo
di un problema di numeri,
di metano o anidride carbonica.
Quando ci rendiamo conto
che i numeri corrispondono
a un innalzamento dei gradi,
[facciamo spallucce].
Poi ci rendiamo conto
che le calotte polari stanno sparendo,
e che poi, quando saranno sparite,
non saranno più capaci
di riflettere i raggi del Sole.
E in più ci rendiamo conto
che i numeri, anche nell'Amazzonia,
non misurano solo
quanto spazio stiamo togliendo,
ma soprattutto di quello che si chiama
il collasso della biodiversità.
C'è una cosa ancora più urgente,
di uno o due gradi centigradi:
ci sono le specie animali,
e anche le specie vegetali -
in generale, la vita sulla Terra
la stiamo distruggendo.
E se facciamo i calcoli, come ho detto,
la maniera più diretta e più veloce
per arrestare questo collasso
è una transizione
a una dieta più sostenibile.
Più sostenibile non vuol dire
[fare] un sacrificio,
e vi spiegherò come si fa.
Però, per me è importante spiegare
la ragione per cui ho fatto
questa transizione
tra la biomedicina,
in cui io lavoravo come bioingegnere
e professore nel campo
della ingegneria tissutale,
quindi lavoravo per rigenerare
organi e tessuti.
Ho lavorato dieci anni, ero professore;
e poi mi sono reso conto
di numeri e di grafici,
e di immagini come queste.
Ognuna di queste linee è una specie
che ha meno di 1000 individui
presenti sul pianeta.
Mille! Non sto dicendo 1.000.000:
calcolati e stimati,
ognuno di questi sono 1000.
Una persona può essere a favore o contro
quelle che si chiamano
le proteine alternative,
che è quello di cui parlerò;
però nessuno è a favore
né della deforestazione,
né della distruzione di boschi e foreste,
né dell'estinzione delle specie.
Nessuno vuole essere la causa
dell'estinzione della specie.
In più, i dati dimostrano
che abbiamo tutto l'interesse,
non solo nei prossimi dieci anni,
a cercare di fare qualcosa,
ma ancora più immediatamente,
ancora più velocemente,
è importante evitare
quelle che sono le pandemie.
La ragione più probabile
della prossima pandemia
è proprio che venga da questa vicinanza:
gli esseri umani
si sono avvicinati moltissimo
alle terre e alle zone selvagge,
e c'è questa trasmissione
di malattie, virus e batteri nuovi.
O, per esempio, la formazione
di batteri resistenti nell'allevamento.
Perché gli diamo, in alcune zone
del mondo soprattutto,
molti antibiotici in forma sistemica.
Quindi si dà antibiotici
in forma preventiva.
Questo non è una cosa buona da mangiare:
ma nemmeno intelligente,
perché si formano delle specie di batteri
che sono resistenti agli antibiotici.
Io lavoravo nel campo della bioingegneria,
ma in particolare negli ultimi anni
mi ero specializzato sulla biostampa.
La biostampa è quella tecnica
che usa una stampante 3D
per creare tessuti microscopici.
E iniziavo a riconoscere
che riuscivo a fare cose
che avevano non solo la struttura,
ma anche la consistenza fibrosa.
Quindi mi sono specializzato
in quelli che si chiamano i biopolimeri.
I biopolimeri possono essere:
le proteine che mangiamo;
i carboidrati che mangiamo;
ma può essere qualsiasi cosa
come il collagene,
che è alla base della struttura
del nostro corpo,
è la proteina principale.
Quindi lavorai con questi ingredienti,
e mi resi conto che ero abbastanza bravo
con questa biostampante,
e vedevo che le persone
più brave del mondo
che cercavano di dimostrare
che la loro tecnologia funzionava,
facevano tessuti complicati,
come per esempio l'orecchio,
che ha il padiglione auricolare.
E quindi, poi mi sono reso conto
che in realtà questa consistenza fibrosa,
dopo aver creato questo orecchio,
era molto simile alla consistenza
di un tessuto animale;
e quindi l'ho portato,
dato che ero a Barcellona
e sono ancora a Barcellona,
da chef leggendari, da Ferran Adrià,
lo ho portato al numero uno al mondo,
El Celler de Can Roca,
e ho chiesto: scusate,
ma tutti quanti fanno hamburger,
tutti quanti fanno polpette;
ma nessuno è riuscito a fare
i tagli interi, le bistecche.
Nessuno è riuscito a fare i filetti,
i petti di pollo: perché?
E ho scoperto che è difficile fare
questa consistenza fibrosa.
Quindi, nel 2017 il primo prototipo
era qualcosa che non era
molto spettacolare, come vedete.
Dato che ero in Spagna,
ho usato il colorante della paella.
(Risate)
E questa è una cosa
che sembrava un po' un gel, diciamo:
non era niente di così incredibile.
Però è vero che ho visto
che c'era molta attrazione mediatica:
mi chiedevano come funziona,
e che cosa si può fare
con questa tecnologia.
Quindi mi sono messo a lavorare un po',
e ho fatto qualcosa con un team, già.
Ho trovato qualche milione di euro
da investitori che volevano
andare più in là
degli hamburger vegetali
che ci sono adesso nel mercato,
e abbiamo creato qualcosa di interessante.
Per esempio, questa è la bistecca vegetale
che è stata considerata
la più realista del mondo.
Poi adesso abbiamo questi prodotti,
già in commercio a Barcellona,
e presto arriveranno nel resto d'Europa
e poi negli Stati Uniti e in Asia.
Può essere sfilacciato
[come] il secondo pollo;
può essere carne sfilacciata,
può essere in formato di Bao,
può essere in formato di tacos;
e quelli più difficili,
che sono questi tagli interi,
per esempio di maiale o di manzo -
come la bistecca, che è
la più difficile da fare.
Poi abbiamo deciso: come si fa a spiegare
che qualcosa può essere,
allo stesso tempo,
più sano -
perché non ha antibiotici, colesterolo;
soprattutto quando lo confrontiamo
con questi filetti che sono sottili,
e non sono un granché quando li cuciniamo.
Ho detto: siamo a Barcellona,
qual è l'unico vantaggio
che abbiamo qua nel Mediterraneo?
A parte la creatività,
abbiamo una gastronomia incredibile.
Ho pensato: perché è
sempre dagli Stati Uniti,
sempre dai Paesi del Nord
che deve arrivare questa innovazione,
soprattutto nella gastronomia?
Noi siamo così incredibili, e ho pensato:
chi sono i migliori del mondo
nella cucina molecolare?
Quindi ho iniziato a collaborare
col ristorante numero tre del mondo,
"Disfrutar Barcelona", aperto
dagli chef di "El Bulli".
Abbiamo formato un team,
adesso siamo un po' di più, siamo in 20.
Non abbiamo creato una stampante,
ma una macchina gigante
che invece di fare 100 grammi all'ora,
come vedevate con l'orecchio
che andava lentissimo,
adesso fa una tonnellata l'ora.
Ognuna delle macchine.
Siamo riusciti ad abbassare
il costo della macchina
a dieci volte di meno di quello che sono
gli straccetti di pollo vegetali,
quindi siamo dieci volte più veloci
e la macchina è dieci volte più economica.
Quindi sono due ordini di superiorità.
E ho pensato:
come hanno fatto le macchine elettriche -
che non erano, diciamo,
il sogno di ogni automobilista -
a passare dal Prius alla Tesla?
Ho pensato: non solo
deve essere sostenibile,
non è importante [solo]
che sia migliore per l'ambiente:
deve essere anche migliore per me.
La specie umana è basata sull'egoismo.
Non dev'essere solo più sostenibile:
deve accelerare come un Ferrari,
e costare dieci volte meno.
Mi spiego?
Quindi, ho pensato
che bisogna fare la stessa cosa.
Allora mi son detto:
"Il filetto possiamo batterlo su tre cose:
sapore; proprietà nutrizionali; e prezzo."
Ho pensato: se riusciamo a fare qualcosa
con grasso infiltrato,
come se fosse Wagyu,
allo stesso prezzo,
qualcosa che può competere
coi tagli interi,
che negli Stati Uniti sono l'80%
di quello che si compra nel supermercato
quando si compra la carne.
E ho pensato: i primi
da battere sono questi,
perché sono quelli che hanno
il volume maggiore,
sono quelli peggiori per l'ambiente
e anche peggiori per noi.
Quindi, adesso stiamo puntando a fare
qualcosa di più sano,
con tutti gli amminoacidi essenziali,
con le fibre,
con solo ingredienti naturali -
non una lista di 30 ingredienti
ma solo, per esempio,
quello che avete visto:
proteine di piselli gialli della Francia;
estratto di alghe della Norvegia;
usiamo l'estratto
di barbabietola, per esempio,
per dare il colore;
e fermenti, per esempio
di lieviti, per dare sapore.
Quindi sono ingredienti
che non sono né chimici,
né qualcosa di strano.
E la nostra tecnologia, come avete visto,
è una tecnologia che forma
queste microfibre.
Però queste microfibre sono fatte
attraverso un sistema meccanico,
quindi noi spingiamo il materiale
attraverso degli spazi microscopici.
Questo materiale sono
proteine vegetali, soprattutto:
sono soggetti a una forza di taglio,
una forza fisica
che permette che queste proteine
si orientino nella stessa direzione
in cui estrudiamo il materiale.
Quindi, riusciamo a trasformare
queste proteine vegetali
in una forma meccanica
e fisica, non chimica,
orientarle come se fossero
proteine animali.
Poi mi son detto:
se lo facciamo con i grandi chef,
possiamo fare qualcosa
che sia più sano, più sostenibile,
ma anche più buono.
Quindi adesso non stiamo puntando ancora
alla Fiorentina, al Wagyu, al T-Bone,
che sono quelli difficili;
ma stiamo puntando a quelli
che sono i peggiori per l'ambiente:
e che corrispondono, di nuovo,
a un disastro per il clima
e per la biodiversità.
E deve essere più sostenibile:
ma le persone non devono
scegliere questo prodotto
per fare un sacrificio,
e sentire che lo fanno
per l'ambiente o per gli animali:
devono pensare che è meglio per loro.
Così in più, se è meglio
per l'ambiente, abbiamo vinto.
Ho fatto altri calcoli, e ho pensato
che mi piacerebbe mandare un messaggio,
quella che si chiama una "Call to Action".
Non si salva il mondo
solo così, come abbiamo visto:
non sono solo le tecnologie.
Bisogna fare formazione e spiegare:
quindi a me piace spiegare come funziona,
perché così le persone
non si spaventano per il cambio
e capiscono che la tecnologia
non è solo qualcosa di cattivo
e può essere qualcosa
che non distrugge la tradizione.
Anzi: i grandi chef giocano,
e sono capaci di creare arte e scienza
utilizzando l'alimentazione.
Se riusciamo a fare qualcosa
che può aiutare in questo senso,
per esempio fermare la deforestazione
e la crisi della biodiversità,
questo deve essere accompagnato
in generale da altri passi.
In totale, mi piacerebbe riassumere
quello che si può fare
per fermare immediatamente
il cambio climatico
e il collasso della biodiversità.
Ed è: una transizione
alle energie rinnovabili -
non possiamo fare molto,
ma possiamo fare qualcosa.
Possiamo aiutare, cercare
di trovare la forma di votare
in modo tale che si acceleri
questa transizione.
La seconda è, immediatamente,
bloccare la deforestazione.
Non è intelligente, ripeto,
nemmeno per una persona egoista
che agisce per sé, e a cui
non importa nulla dell'ambiente.
Non è intelligente distruggere
i boschi e le zone tropicali,
che si sono formate in milioni di anni,
per questioni, anche, di pandemie,
questioni di salute
e questioni, come sapete,
di innalzamento delle temperature.
Il terzo passo è un'alimentazione
a consumo ridotto di carne.
È un'alimentazione più sana:
tenete conto che l'allevamento intensivo
è nato pochi anni fa.
Noi pensiamo che sia
parte della tradizione,
della cultura gastronomica italiana;
ma la dieta mediterranea è famosa
perché si mangia meno carne
che in altre culture.
E avere zone vietate alla pesca
in cui si possa creare questo equilibrio,
in cui i pesci si possano rigenerare.
E evitare, per esempio,
la distruzione di aree
che sono importantissime per l'equilibrio,
come le zone della barriera corallina.
Quindi, vi lascio
con un messaggio di speranza:
[vogliamo] informare
sulle nuove tecnologie,
e farlo con prodotti
che siano di altissima qualità,
e lavorare con grandi chef
e avere un prodotto come questo
che sia sorprendentemente buono,
sorprendentemente più sano
e più sostenibile,
e magari trovarlo prima in ristoranti top,
dove pensiamo che questo
prodotto lo scegliamo
non perché sia un sacrificio per me,
ma perché è una cosa nuova
che voglio provare, e forse è migliore
e vi piace di più della carne
che possiamo trovare nei supermercati.
(Applausi)